i'm an annie and some people call me
like miss h
people call me hath so feel free call me
anything but anne
so turns out all this time we've been
calling anne hathaway by the wrong name
things are not going to go your way a
lot of the time
the big revelation went down on
tuesday's episode of the tonight show
when host jimmy fallon said that he
heard a little rumor that her close
friends
call her annie call me annie yeah
everybody everybody call me annie please
yeah she like borderline
begged us to call her annie and
explained that the whole
anne thing began when she was just
starting her career
when i was 14 years old i did a
commercial and i and i
i had to get my sag card and they asked
me what do you want your name
to be and i'm like well it should be my
name my name's anne hathaway like and
and i never and so that seemed like the
right choice but it never occurred to me
that for the rest of my life
people will call me anne and miss annie
hathaway said that when people call her
anne she assumes she's in trouble the
only person who ever calls me ann is my
mother and she only does it when she's
really mad at me
like really mad and so i every time
like i step out in public and someone
calls my name i think they're gonna yell
at me
oh and the oscar winner had a little psa
for her fans
you should call her annie too people are
like and i'm like what what did i do
dude i'm a man so please seriously just
feel free
it's not people are so lovely they don't
want to be presumptuous
and so i think they come up with
workarounds on set because no because
because the truth is nobody's
comfortable calling me anne
ever it doesn't fit it's not i'm a nanny
and some people call me like miss h
people call me hath so feel free call me
anything but anne
well i don't know about you but i'm
shook i just try not to embarrass myself
but that wasn't the only big reveal
annie made
first first what is your first
celebrity crush leonardo dicaprio come
on
yeah the 38 year old actress also dished
on her first
celeb crush he was on that show for a
while
um pains i don't remember i just
remember being like
hi wow yeah same girl
same annie she's just like us
excuse me i thought today's subject was
gravity
and when it caught up with the actress
on tuesday to talk about her new hbo max
flick locked
down she proved her relatability yet
again when she revealed her family's
go-to
quarantine meal clearly we've all been
on lockdown for quite
some time and getting to know our
spouses our partners or children more
than we ever had
so what is the most interesting new
thing that you've learned
i'll give you an interesting tidbit
frozen pizza twice a week is a very
healthy option because it's good for
your mental health
absolutely because who wants to be
cooking and cleaning all day with the
dishes and then not me and not my
husband and we both chip in in that
respect so sometimes we look at each
other we just go pizza
you